a reef and siku are a hard-working
couple who own a carpet shop in Istanbul
one day a reef sold friend logar along
with his assistant comes to the shop and
reveals that he has discovered something
crazy in a nearby place however when
they reach the place logar apprehends a
reef and ties him up it turns out this
was all his plan to steal a Reef's wife
moreover the object which he was
referring to is actually a time machine
using some Advanced mechanism the evil
logar then transforms into an Arif
lookalike and reveals his plan to
reproduce with siku when the real Arif
tries to smack talk logar's assistant
activates the time machine and sends him
one million years back in time boy this
guy's Revenge better be good seconds
after a reef arrives in the Cretaceous
Period where the dinosaurs are still
active as he wanders around the place in
horror he stumbles across some Apes who
are the first of their kind and are yet
to evolve left with no choice a reef
starts living with them and tries to
educate them hoping that they'll evolve
days turn into months and the winter
season arrives when a reef goes to
relieve himself his pee instantly
freezes indicating that the temperatures
are equivalent to the present day North
Pole with nothing else to do a reef has
made a structure out of the Frozen
peasicles unfortunately even after
several months of intense teaching the
Apes haven't shown any signs of progress
this makes a reef realize that he cannot
make it back home if he continues to
live with these clueless Apes therefore
he Ventures out on his own into the
forest in search of human civilization
along the way he encounters a ferocious
T-Rex who Roars at him a reef is
initially frightened but he soon
realizes that the dinosaur is actually a
mother and she is just trying to protect
her offspring's eggs seeing this Arif
adopts a friendly approach and backs off
the dinosaur's territory the T-Rex
appreciates his gesture and gives him a
huge honey Nest as a Parting Gift her
Reef happily accepts it but only to
realize that he is now angered a huge
bee the Beast stings him and continues
to chase him prompting him to run for
his life a reef eventually manages to
shake off the Bee by hiding behind a
tree but soon starts to get dizzy from
the sting and eventually falls to the
ground as his eyes closed shut he
notices two cavemen on the tree but
before he could react the Primitive men
tranquilize him later Arif gains
Consciousness inside a cave surrounded
by a bunch of cavemen chanting strange
prayers it turns out they are afraid of
a reef as he is a stranger and they plan
to kill him luckily a wreath can speak
their language and he convinces the
leader of the tribe dimi that he is from
the future and is not a threat to them
suddenly a man announces that the
arrogians have arrived it turns out a
rogians are a separate tribe led by The
Savage named carga and they have been
oppressing dimy's tribe for quite some
time during each visit the arrogans
torment the villagers and seize their
food intools this time karga is here to
take three of the strongest cavemen for
a special ritual unfortunately harif is
shortlisted as one of them when he tries
to refuse karga shoots him with a
tranquilizer knocks him unconscious and
then takes him to his village on the way
one of the Savages named tasso has an
accident he hits his head on a stone and
falls down from his horse breaking his
arm in the process as he cries in pain
cargo proceeds to bury tosso as if he is
dead Arif who has already woken up is
stunned and he immediately intervenes he
tells the Savages that tosso is not dead
but he has only fractured his arm he
then makes a makeshift cast for his
broken arm surprisingly tosso can now
feel his arm again and he thanks Arif
for saving his life once they reach the
village it's revealed that the place is
actually led by karga's nephew Kalia who
is also tasso's Father the Father and
Son ketchup and karga asks tasso about
the handmade mask he found in tasso's
room tasso proudly reveals that he made
it from trees bark but this upsets Kalia
as he wants his son to be a Savage
Warrior not an artist Kalia then
narrates an incident from his childhood
that claimed his father Kumo's life one
day a strange circular spaceship
descended from the sky carrying two
strange visitors they gave Kumo a ball
as a gift and got back into their
spaceship unfortunately an overexcited
Kumo ran after them to bid them goodbye
and in the process he got burned to
death by the spaceship's engine ever
since then Kalia has hated new things
and inventions and since he believes
that his father is in heaven he is built
an extremely tall tower many people have
tried to climb the tower to bring Kumo
back but none have succeeded or survived
it turns out that carga brought the
three strong men from dini's tribe to
send them up the tower however Arif
volunteers to go by himself to
everyone's surprise he slowly climbs the
tower and eventually manages to reach
the top there he encounters a strange
man who he assumes to be Kumo harif
plans to take the man back to the ground
but ends up frightening him causing him
to fall to his death upset a reef slowly
starts descending and when he reaches
the ground the orogian tribe is stunned
to see someone return alive from the
tower they erupt in Joy making the
situation somewhat joyous Kalia is upset
that Arif couldn't bring his father back
but nevertheless he forgives him tasso
is also so impressed by a Reef's
gallantry and he starts drawing his
picture on a stone Arif compliments his
craft and tasso gives him a rare glimpse
of his collection there Arif notices a
hidden drawing of a girl named Mimi from
the other Village it turns out tasso has
a major crush on her this reminds The
Reef of his beloved wife siku and he
pleads with dasso to supply all the
tools available so that he can return to
his time tasso calls it impossible as
his father Kalia collects all equipment
and locks it in a cave forbidding
everyone from using any of it however
when a reef promises to set tasso up
with Mimi he finally agrees to help
acquire those tools later that night
tasso and Arif sneak into the cave in
search of tools Unfortunately they are
soon caught by karga who takes the two
to Kalia as expected the ruler of the
village is disappointed that his son has
become a thief and quickly disowns him
because of this an upset tasso leaves
the village with a reef in the next
scene the two wander around the forest
until they come across Mimi and her
friends bathing in a river Mimi is
hostile to tell also because of his
background but Arif changes her
perception by showing her a lovely
woman's tattoo that tasso is made on his
back the group then returns to dimi's
Village and Arif Reveals His plan to
start a new civilization he tells dimi
about the thousands of useful Gadgets in
kalia's cave and asks for his help in
stealing them excited with the prospect
of having modern tools and technology
dimi and his people immediately get on
board with the plan the following night
Arif and tasso again infiltrate kalia's
cave and load all the necessary tools
into a cartwheel then the villagers help
them carry the cartwheel back to the
village in no time a reef begins making
all the necessary inventions that have
helped mankind evolve and over the
course of the next few months everyone
in the village is accustomed to the new
privileges because of a reef they have
evolved several thousand years faster
making life very easy for them the women
can now cook food and the children can
go to school Arif is declared the
minister of the village but he's not
happy as he hasn't noticed any change in
his people's intelligence harif needs to
go find some mushrooms on the other hand
Kalia event actually finds out that the
cave has been robbed by a reef and tasso
Furious he sends his uncle karga to kill
them but when the latter arrives at the
Village he has taken aback to see all
the new inventions he immediately
demands that they be handed to him
however Arif mocks and humiliates him in
front of his people this infuriates
karga and he promises to come back with
his army to take revenge one day a reef
takes tosso Mimi and the others on a
picnic to a nearby jungle sadly when
they return they find the entire Village
ransacked it turns out the aerogians
took everything from the village fed up
with these feuds a reef approaches Kalia
and proposes a solution a six-man
football game if his team wins Kalia
will have to return all the equipment
that he stole earlier and if a reef were
to lose he will build Kalia a tower
which will be long enough to retrieve
his missing father surprisingly Kalia
agrees without hesitation it's then
revealed that the orogians have been
playing ball games in memory of his late
father Kumo whose special ball has
become somewhat of a treasure hence
Kalia has no problem whatsoever in
making a team he picked six fiercest
fittest and strongest man for the big
occasion on the other hand a reef also
starts looking for players but
unfortunately for him no one has ever
heard of the term football just then
Mimi reveals that there's a former
erogan goalkeeper named kuhara in the
village it turns out kuhara retired from
football after he conceded eight goals
in one match just like Barcelona did
against Bayern a reef tries to convince
him to play but he refuses seeing this
dimi steps up to be the goalkeeper of
the team meanwhile Arif and tasso become
the forward Strikers and the rest of the
village is made up of other random
villagers with this a reef and his team
start undergoing gruesome training while
Mimi and other women prepare the team's
football jerseys and just after a few
days a reef FC gets the hang of the game
and starts playing elegantly that's not
how soccer Works soon the important day
arrives everyone's pumped about the game
but unfortunately the arrogans start
dominating right from the get-go they
easily out muscle their opponents and
score four spectacular goals but
surprisingly just before the halftime a
player for from a reef FC manages to
pull one back he celebrates so violently
that he ends up running into the nearby
flames in the halftime discussion a
worried a reef reveals that he is
actually an alien from another planet
who has been living on Earth because of
the good food here in fact he has some
superpowers which can easily turn the
game in their favor harif also mentions
that he didn't use the powers up until
now because he feared hurting someone
but now that his team's Victory is on
the line he will have to become an alien
surprisingly instead of being upset for
hiding such a big fact from them the
villagers get intrigued and start
encouraging him to Showcase his best
performance soon the second half begins
and a reef using his powers completely
dominates the play with his Supernatural
acrobatics and impeccable Vision he
leads his team to score three goals
hence tying the game at 4-4 In the Heat
of the game tosso gets into a fight with
one of the erogians resulting in a
penalty for them dimi saves the penalty
but his hands get injured and he is
rendered unfit to play now with no
goalkeeper on the roster kuhara steps
forward and volunteers to play he soon
turns into a brick wall and saves
everything that has thrown his way at
last with only seconds remaining harif
leaps in the air and launches a
ferocious shot which ends up being the
winning goal The Village erupts and
cheers and Kalia also applauds the
opposing team he mentions that he will
keep his part of the deal and stay away
from the villagers from now on but
despite the victory a reef is sad he
believes that logar has already taken
his wife siku hostage hence he plans to
leave the village and wander off once
and for all before leaving he gifts his
watch to tasso and his engagement ring
to Mimi suddenly a bright flash appears
and siku appears out of thin air a reef
is elated and puzzled to see his wife
siku then reveals that after a reef left
with logar she got on the internet and
learned about a million year old ring
and watch that was found in a cave by a
group of archaeologists when siku
researched more about the ring and watch
she realized that they were in fact a
Reeves she then connected all the dots
and deduced that the a reef in front of
her was an imposter logar hence she held
him at gunpoint and interrogated him
about her husband's location at last she
operated logar's time machine to arrive
here shortly after the couple Bid
Farewell to all the villagers and
returned back to their timeline and as
soon as they reach home they send logar
to the Primitive Village at first the
villagers assumed that he is a reef and
try talking to him politely but when the
Arrogant logar starts hurling
obscenities they realize he's an
imposter that was quick why did siku
have to research a bunch of caves and
[ __ ] to make matters worse Kalia and the
others also learned that it was logar's
spaceship that came to their Village
many years back and killed Kumo seeing
the angry mob logar finally starts
panicking and requests the people leave
him alone but no one listens to him the
movie ends as the villagers slowly
approach logar to apprehend him but
before that a T-Rex pops up out of
nowhere and gobbles him up subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching